[موسيقى]
جائحه كورونا الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اسعار النفط اضطراب اسواق الاسهم
التضخم ورفع اسعار الفائده ومخاوف الكساد
[موسيقى]
ازمه تلو الاخرى تمتد اثارها على الاقتصاد
الى كل دول العالم وبالتالي الى اموالك
الشخصيه
والان تلوح ازمه جديده في الافق تهدد
بضربه قويه اخرى للاقتصاد العالمي وهي
تعثر ما يعرف بيولوك الظل في الصين
[موسيقى]
يعمل مقرض الظل بما في ذلك الشركات
الائتمانيه خارج النظام المصرفي الرسمي
لكنهم جزء مهم للغايه من اقتصاد الصين
تقدم بنوك الظل خدمات شبيهه بخدمات البنوك
العاديه مثل الاقتراض والودائع وتسهل حركه
الاموال من المستثمرين الى البنيه التحتيه
والعقارات ومجالات الاقتصاد الاخرى
تقدر قيمه استثمارات بنوك الظل في الصين
بحوالي ثلاثه تريليونات دولار حافظه
البنوك الصينيه لفتره طويله على اسعار
فائده منخفضه على الودائع المصرفيه مما
مكن بنوك الظل التي تدفع عوائد اعلى من
جذب المستثمرين
تمتعت بنوك الظل لسنوات بسمعه جيده في
الصين كادوات استثمار امنه لكنها فقدت
الكثير من الثقه مؤخرا فماذا حدث
ادت المشاكل الاقتصاديه في الصين الى فشل
بعض بنوك الظل وانذرت بعضها الاخر بتكبد
خسائر هائله مما يثير المخاوف من ازمه
ماليه اكبر واوسع
شركه جونغ رونك احد اكبر بنوك الظل في
الصين تخلفت عن سداد العوائد للعملاء في
اغسطس 2023
تجمع العملاء خارج مكاتب الشركه في
احتجاجات استدعت تواجدا امنيا مكثفا ايضا
الاموال التي تديرها الشركه كانت تقدر
نهايه عام 2022
بحوالي 87 مليار دولار لعملاء من الشركات
والافراد الاثرياء
فماذا سيحدث يحذر الخبراء من ان سقوط بلوك
الظل قد يؤدي الى تاثير الدومينو عبر
الاقتصاد العالمي لان بنوك الظل لا تمثل
مشكله في الصين فحسب
وقال فيليبتيز من شركه تيس الامريكيه
لاداره الاصول ان هذا النوع من المنظمات
موجود في جميع انحاء العالم مضيفا ان ما
يحدث في الصين يخلق مخاطر رئيسيه ومخاطر
العدوى وراى تيس ان مصدر القلق الاكبر هو
ما اذا كانت البنوك داخل النظام المصرفي
قد اقرضت بوليودك الظل واصبحت الان معرضه
للخطر مؤكدا ان ذلك قد يخلق ازمات ويؤثر
على الاقتصاد الاوسع واسواق الاسهم حول
العالم
[موسيقى]